[Music]
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
it's based on george r martin's book
firing blood vol 1
and on mars yet unfinished fire and
blood vol 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary egg and the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
that's fire and blood volume 1. the
atana released fire and blood volume
2 will continue from where part 1 ended
with rhaenyra targaryen's son aegon iii
reign and will cover blackfyre
rebellions the war with dorne and go all
the way to the mad king
and robert's rebellion that tended
targaryen dynasty
the key event of the prequel will be the
dance of the dragon
a targaryen civil war this summer it was
reported that hbo has released a casting
call for george armon's favorite
targaryen
daemon targaryen a key figure from this
time period of the dance of the dragons
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and executive
producers
george r martin will also serve as
executive producer
the dance of the dragons was the most
devastating war in the history of the
seven kingdoms
the war of succession between aegon ii
and his half sister rhaenyra over their
father viserys the first throne
both of them thought they belonged on
the iron throne when people started
declaring for one of them or the other
their fight divided the kingdoms in two
targaryens fought targaryens brothers
fought brothers
dragons fought the dragons by the time
it was over thousands were dead
the conflict would prove to be
incredibly destructive for not only
house targaryen
but large parts of westeros as well
additionally devastated the targaryen's
dragon population
ultimately leading to their extinction
within a few decades
they never truly recovered by the end of
the reign of king viserys first
targaryen 20 dragons were alive
the majority of these died during the
civil war called the dance of the
dragons
which began in 129 ac and lasted until
mid
131 ac one of the main characters in
this series is going to be daemon
targaryen
demon targaryen also known as prince of
the city lord fleet bottom and the rogue
prince had many titles throughout his
life
prince sir commander of the city watch
master of coin master of loss
king of the stepstones and the narrow
sea protector of the realm
daemon was the most controversial man of
his lifetime
an audacious rogue prince and adventurer
who seemed made of good and evil in
equal measure
there was never a man so loved and so
reviled and at the same time as he was
during the dance of the dragons as the
husband of his niece rhaenyra he
supported his wife's claim
and he was considered by many the most
dangerous man in westeros
he was rhaenyra's second husband
following sir leonard valorian
and she was his third wife prince damon
was the most experienced warrior of his
time
and wielded the valyrian steel blade
dark sister a dragon rider whose dragon
was characters
daemon declared himself the king of the
stepstones and the narrow sea
daemon was a skilled warrior described
in the histories as dashing daring and
dangerous
he was also ambitious impetuous
mercurial immoral reckless
and quick to take offense he is
described as being as charming as he was
hot
tempered and it seems that hbo already
found perfect fit for the character
travis fimmel whom you might know as
ragnar from vikings
it's not yet confirmed that he will play
the role 100
but it's reported by portuguese
entertainment website that he's in talks
with hbo to play the role of daemon
daemon is a versatile character who
constantly switches between being
charming and loving too crazy and
bloodthirsty
and i have to stand by hbo's side here
as in my opinion travel's female would
be a great choice to play this georgia
armoire's favorite character from this
time period
daemon inspired loyalty in 106 ac
daemon led an army to invade the stepped
stones in the southern narrow sea
with the support of lord corliss
valerion and his fleet
and with the use of daemon's dragon
carraxis after conquering all but two of
the islands
daemon declared himself the king of the
stepstones and an air of scene 109 ac
being crowned by coralie's the sea snake
by the year 120 ac daemon married two
times and had two daughters
but both wives died in 120 ac daemon
married again
this time to his niece princess rhaenyra
targaryen
this marriage was performed suddenly
without the knowledge of king viserys
the first targaryen
and was scandalous since neither lena
nor lane or velaryon
daemon's previous wife and rynera's
previous husband had been dead for six
months
according to mushroom it was daemon who
arranged the death of lenore
by paying sir corey to kill him thus
making rhaenyra available to mary
daemon and rhaenyra had two sons
together prince aegon the younger born
in 120 ac
and prince visery is born in 122 ac
while viserys the first targaryen had
decreed rhaenyra targaryen his heir
sir kristen cole crowned queen allison
hightower's son aegon ii targaryen
after viserys's death in 129 ac
the greens took advantage of being in
king's landing at a time of the death of
king viserys
and took the throne while most of the
blacks were at dragonstone
at the start of the civil war called the
dance of the dragons prince daemon had
more experience in warfare
than all their foes combined during
rhaenyra's rival coronation on
dragonstone daemon plays the crown of
king jahiri's first targaryen on the
head of his wife
proclaiming her the queen and claiming
himself the protector of the realm
daemon led the assault on harrenhal
capturing the ruined castle from its
castellan
after hearing of the death of his
stepson prince lucerus valerian at the
hands of his nephew
prince aemond targaryen daemon through
his spymaster
and former mistress maiseria hired blood
and cheese to kill a son of fake on the
second
son for her son daemon abandoned
harrenhal when eamon and kristen began
marching
on the great castle with a host of
greens instead
daemon flew charaxes back to king's
landing and assisted rhaenyra with
capturing the city
he made his niece and wife rhaenyra the
queen of the seven kingdoms
daemon challenged the aemond waiting for
13 days at harrenhal
until aemond stopped burning the
riverlands to come to face him
on the 14th day epic battle above the
god's eye finally happened
it was an aerial duel that took place in
the skies above harehole and the god's
eye
between two of the most powerful living
dragons vergara and characters
and their writers prince eamonn and
prince daemon targaryen
the duel was said to be a sight to see
the sun was setting as the two dragons
took to the sky
so bright was the dragonfire that small
folk feared the sky was aflame
when characters attacked vegar she
ripped upon his stomach and tore one of
his
wings but then characters fast and his
jaws surround her throat in death grip
these injuries forced them both to cease
flying
and as they tumbled through the water
below daemond dueled eamonn to death
as he never fastened his saddle daemon
stood up on charaxes
and lapped at aymond whereupon he drove
his dark sister through aemon's eye and
through his neck
just a second before hitting the water
the battle above the god's eye
ended in the deaths of both riders and
both the dragons
daemon was 49 when he died unlike
eamonn's body however
demons was never found singers say that
daemon lived to spend the rest of his
days in secret with nettles
but most historians disagree if you'd
like to know all details about the
upcoming game of thrones prequel series
make sure to watch my video named game
of thrones prequel show explained
in which i as the title says itself
explain everything about it
as well as by reading the book fire and
blood does not mean you will know
exactly what will happen on the show
the books are history of house targaryen
written by a maester
who relies on questionable sources that
often differ from one another
and even george r martin said that its
accuracy is not the best
once again let me remind you that firing
blood is a complete history of house
targaryen
written by george rr martin from
perspective of archmaester gildane
who wrote it many decades after the
events took place the show unlike the
book will contain truth
it will depict what actually happened
not the change history
fake or semi-true not what might or
might not have happened
we'll know exactly what happened in this
time period when the show comes out
and that's why you cannot just read fire
and blood book and think you would know
what actually happened or what will
happen on the show
damon targaryen will be one of the main
characters and probably my favorite
in fire and blood guilden uses these
words to best describe daemon
over the centuries house targaryen has
produced both great men and monsters
prince damon was both in his day there
was not a man so admired so beloved
and so reviled in all westeros he was
made of light and darkness in
equal parts to some he was a hero to
others the blackest of villains
this is a good description of daemon the
best description comes from george r
martin of course i'm notorious for my
love of grey characters
and one of the greatest characters in
the entirety of westeros is daemon
targaryen the rogue prince
uh we we took one of the sidebars and
made a separate story out of it the
rogue prince damon is
the younger brother of king viserys the
first for a time he was the heir to the
throne
when viserys had no children and then
viserys started having children and he
stopped being the heir to the throne
he's a notorious bad boy
a rogue in every sense of the word he
was a rival for
viserys sister and his own niece
rhaenyra
and then later he became the husband of
rhaenyra he switches sides several times
you never know what side he's going to
come down
on he's a very colorful and
unpredictable character
and um i think he has to rank up there
as my favorite but the the book is full
of uh
what i hope are interesting characters
anyways if you want more details about
the prequel make sure to check out that
video
let me know your thoughts about
everything the prequel its characters
especially daemon and about travis
fimmel being in talks with hbo to play
it
in the comment section down below thank
you so much for watching and i hope to
see you in the next one
peace